welcome everyone to the data science
hangout and welcome back to all the
familiar faces and
to those joining for the first time
um
we really want to use this time to focus
on questions that are most important to
you all
so
no agenda
everyone's welcome to join in live or
put any questions you have in the chat
we do also have a slido for any
questions that you want to ask
anonymously too so
rob if you wouldn't mind putting that in
the zoom chat that would be great
and just a quick note that we will
record this session so we'll post it up
to
youtube and as you may have heard us
just chatting about also take little
snippets um
of really important points as well and
and put them there
but for today i'm joined by my co-host
oli chief data officer at the city of
reykjavik oli is focused on bringing
value from data to residents of
reykjavik and
holy i'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a bit about
your team and the work that you do
yeah of course i'm happy to be here
i think this is an important
and
disgusting framework for us to have and
this is uh an interesting field and i
think many of us are doing these things
for the
some of some of the things are being
done for the first time or like they're
relatively new we need to learn from
each other
at least in my case so
as ashford mentioned i'm the chief data
officer of the city of regularly and
data is there this is playing a central
role
recently and
and it's relatively new i think that's
the reason why we need to keep the
discussion going and learn from each
other is like
we're kind of inventing things that
haven't been there before so so i'm
gonna go out online and claim this so
just a few words on my story
and well i'll switch from icelandic to
english it takes some time to get into
gear you know you know how it is to
icelandic speakers
um
so a few words of me
my background is in mathematical
statistics i did my phd
seven years back finished seven years
back and
which was which was on
basic hierarchical modeling and all my
modeling was carried out of course in
our
like the same person
and
so
when i was doing my my phd research i
was also doing a lot of statistical
consultancy both for
starting companies for big companies
also within the academy
so once i graduated i spent a year in
postdoc about that but i felt so that i
needed to be somewhere else and
so after
this after phd i worked for a company
called quizop it was a computer gaming
company here in iceland and after that i
went to atlas retail that is also a high
sided company
and specializing in poc software
apos the software after that i was with
lanspunk as a senior data scientist
where i laid the ground for the use of
machine learning at the bank
which was extremely interesting because
it wasn't just risk related it was
data science in general and what can we
do with data science and that was the
point that i was trying to
get to earlier is that using data
science as a part of your operations as
a whole that is relatively new i'm
really familiar with these things are
new
but including them and incorporating
these aspects into your business so it's
just it's not it's just a nice to have
it's a must-have that's nice that's fun
and and that is i feel like gives me a
sense of purpose at work
and so but after after two years once
pumpkin it continued
i hate to cut you off here but i'm
getting a little bit of feedback in the
audio and i don't know if it might be
from the airpods so i don't know if we
could maybe try just using the computer
audio yeah of course of course let's try
this yes there we go that's better oh
yes perfect like
i think they're starting to break down
but uh that's another note
um so
um
my journey at the city started
two years ago um
and the city council decided that
hey we wanna be a modern city we we are
nothing without data and that is just
something that the city council has been
discussing and i find that fascinating
they realize that data place essential
role in the operations of organizations
these days
and and are aware of
big companies like google and netflix
and all of these things
amazon they're data driven and
and being data driven is something that
we need to
breathe and feel and it isn't just
this is along the lines that isn't just
nice to have it's a must-have in your
business
um
so
but it needs to
it needs to have some point it needs to
bring some value
and
this is something that i would like to
emphasize and
on this discussion today is that
um
being
a part of our organization as a data
science team or a data science leader or
data leader or whatever
isn't about
algorithms or data science in that sense
or cool structures or
or cool inference methods
it's about seeing where you can bring
value
to somebody in your business and i
this is of course obvious when you
discuss that but you need to be okay
with
like letting go of this amazing model we
spent
weeks training
and
and realized that if it isn't bringing
value then you're doing something that
is pointless for the organization it
isn't pointless for you but it's
pointless for the team as a whole
and
i feel like if you don't see the value
and you're not okay with having these
discussions
then you won't make any progress within
the organization
so
we
the data science team at the city of
reykjavik we we have this
um
momentum from the city council but we
need to bring
bring the action to the other
departments in the sense that we need to
show them how we bring value
and
i feel like this is uh for at least the
team or the team leader or somebody has
to be responsible for this aspect of the
data science operations
um
and
bringing value
isn't only your responsibility
it's
it's your and your clients or your
stakeholders responsibility
and it can only happen
in a dialogue in an open discussion with
your with your stakeholders
let me give you an example like
we have various takeovers at the city
the residents of sikh raid york city are
the largest stakeholder but let's
let's demystify this let's take an easy
example like one of our biggest
stakeholders that is within the city
are all the departments like school and
lisa and they know their business they
know what they're about and and we can't
like
do data science for them without
working with them and having a dialogue
with them such that they understand the
value they're bringing
like
how are we adding to your operation with
with data science
and
so
so being in this role you have to be
okay with hey i need to explain things
that are obvious to me
and realize that not everybody is as
excited about data as you
and
and be okay with that
you need to
you need to have a discussion with all
with other stakers like hey this is
great you can do this did you realize
that and this is awesome
and and they need to fit it into their
own framework
and i feel like in my experience like
be
energetic about this
be
mindful of their needs and if they're
like bringing up the wall and and being
difficult there might be a reason for
that that it has nothing to do with you
or data science it's all about them
and and slowly but surely you can bring
value
and
and realize that people are different
and what i find amazing in this job is
like
data science is more about people than
it is about ai like
isn't that weird you can't just sit in
some corner corner and strain air models
and expect things to be amazing
so you have to have
this
in your team
so
a few words about my awesome team and i
feel so privileged to be a part of it
so
i have
i have thoughts on how to assemble a
team like this and
and
of course there are certain categories
and so certain domains that you want to
make sure you
have
check check in some box
and of course you need to have like
these data engineers they are
responsible for for getting data into
some some sort of domain like a data
warehouse or data lake or whatever
technology you're using
their responsibility for the underlying
framework
and and
i i often have like this metaphor for
using a data pyramid and the first layer
of the pyramid that you're trying to
build
are the data foundations getting data
cleaning it and maintaining it all of
these things i i'm just assuming that
everybody here is relatively familiar
with that
and
the skill set there is a bit different
than the skill set you're
that you're looking for when you're
looking for state scientists
but it isn't
there is an intersection between those
two domains but
they aren't necessarily holding the same
um
so
once you have these strong data
foundations and and
and
then you need to bring in the data
scientists the the talent set that can
go into the data and
find patterns and bring value
and i think it's incredibly important
that the data scientists are okay with
with maintaining an open dialogue with
their stakeholders and
and explaining things that are obvious
to them like hey you know this is the
mean this is the median
and just be okay with that put on your
teacher's hat and enjoy the ride
and i think it's much more about that
than training extremely complicated
models at least in some cases and and i
guess this varies between business
domains but at the city most of the
effort is in the dialogue but we
sometimes hit
and problems that are are
difficult in some sense are involved
and that's fantastic but that's just
part of the game that's not the whole
game
and that is the second layer in the
pyramid and i think the third layer is
what i call and i think in the
literature is called data ops
and
and that is operationalizing
some of your products your data products
and your data products might be apis
apis that you expose to your clients it
might be connections into excel or power
bi or whatever it might be like um
cine dashboards and we use a lot of
senior dashboards and in our case
the operational side is maintaining and
designing and operationalizing
dashboards and
and also access to models and access to
plots
so in our our particular case it's it's
it's in our studio connect and
so all of these things um
are aiming to you're trying to build
this pyramid to get to the top part of
it which is bringing value you can have
all these nice things
but if you aren't bringing value to
somebody and and
i'd like to emphasize that
it's not necessarily only monetary value
it can be value in the form of better
services in a better experience for the
residents of your city like in our case
you need to define it and you need to be
able to master it and then you need to
live by it we brought value through this
product
in this sense
um
i feel like when you are when everybody
in the team realizes that you get this
positive feedback loop into your team
from your clients
that you and your team belong to
something bigger than yourself
and bigger than your team
and
then
at least in my case and i i think you
can talk for the team as well
and
then you're more
like let's say energetic about going to
work the next day
and and the team consists of data
engineers it consists of data scientists
and dave the ops and project manager and
me
and and i if there's some extra obvious
things that i just like to say out loud
everybody knows this but i'm still going
to say it upload
you need to have
a
diversified team so embrace diversity
it's so obvious but it's so true you
need to be diverse in aids you need to
be diverse in gender and
and in all of these things then that you
can't beat that person because then you
bring different mindset into the mix
and and i also feel like when when
you're not surrounded by people that are
just like you
you you automatically become a better
part like more professional and try to
bring your a game all the time that is
just something that i think is true i
have no idea what is true or not
but it's the thing about having
different mindsets and and don't
discriminate towards aids like
like somebody who's been 30 years in in
the game is not too old for data science
and there's something that i had a
discussion of this recently
um i i just
in this particular field which is this
crazy mix of
science and thoughts and and disciplines
and discussions and being humane
then i think it's more important than
ever to diversify and that's just like
how i think about things and
and one other thing that that i'd like
to mention is that
so
it's so important to get the sense that
you belong to something bigger and
and there are various ways to do that
but i think
you mainly do that through your
stakeholder relationships and building
up a good team spirit
but
um i have some tricks that i'd like to
share and
for building up my fantastic team spirit
and belonging to something bigger than
yourself
um
first off i'd like to emphasize the
importance of
um
being agile in your development and i'm
not saying that
because adsel is cool or the
or right the main thing i take from an
ad select pros is that you have dailies
and you have opportunities to set these
and take these big goals
like you want to run a marathon but
you're gonna break it into pieces
and
and
when you do that
you realize that hey
this overall big goal is not something
that i need to think about all the time
i only think about individual small
goals
and that is nice because when you reach
them and and
then you can celebrate with your team
and that is then you get this positive
feedback loop that hey i did something
important i didn't complete this whole
marathon
but we reached our short sighted goal
like short-term goals
and
and
on daily or planning i shared that with
my team and got this positive feedback
look that hey i did well
if i didn't you know break this goal
into pieces you're losing these
opportunities
to re-enlighten the spirit for the sense
of purpose in your team
and i think during work with
times and you work from home i think
that's actually important when you have
team members sitting at home
and and they kind of
think like who am i why who why am i
here
sitting in the same seat all day long i
need to belong to something
and
yeah so i'm totally sold on these tricks
and
and the second trick that
these are just the tricks like you can
you can't just just do these things and
hope for the best this is just extra
flavor um but i'm really keen on
allowing the team to have their own time
on fridays just work on something that i
think is interesting not necessarily
projects but it has to be data related
to data science related
it can be something that hasn't been
like can be a project
that and like in our particular case one
of the
of these awesome team members decided to
play around with data on
garbage collection calendars those
weren't
in a digital format here at the city so
now
he he built up this interactive garbage
calendar which is now a hit product at
regular city
which is which is something that was
totally unknown but
he just rolled the dice and we thought
that was cool and now this is our most
popular date product
but these are also the times and
opportunities for you
for the team members or for your team to
upskill themselves
and don't be too strict about it and
and
just like hey go play but
go play
in data science right
um because
that's like having like this one lottery
ticket you never know what comes out of
it worst case scenario your team members
know something more
and
and yeah i i i love it i already have a
product now
from that lottery operationalized
so yeah it was totally worth it in my
case
there's so many more things just
just
please ask away i'd love to share them
and
i love that that i or that point you
made that data science is more about the
people and i see rob you just put that
in the chat as well but only i know i i
have the advantage of knowing a few more
of the use cases from the team have from
our past conversations but i think it'd
be awesome to also maybe share
a few other examples of what the team is
working on to provide value to
i i have slides maybe i i can still show
those slides i can also spin up some of
these dashboards oh it's it's okay just
kind of like a few i i mean i love the
swimming pool example but i'm sure yeah
okay
okay i love the swimming pool example
because that is one of these um
surprisingly complicated project
complicated complicated process that
okay okay
so let me let me
let me take you back so
so
icelanders they really like swimming
pools and that is something to do with
uh that
iceland sits on this geothermal spot
for you guys who are not aware of we
have an active active volcano now and if
you don't believe me i can send pictures
i could almost see it from my windows
sometimes just right there
so
so this is a a geothermally active
island
and so we have these geothermal plants
scattered around reykjavik city and they
provide the city with
with with abundance of of hot water and
electricity
so as a result we have a lot of swimming
pools and uh like
crazy
crazy many swimming pools
and this is i think
uh a raid like ice
i think this is the most favorite
pastime activities for icelanders to go
too simple
and
but since it's so popular and it's also
popular with tourists and
is that we have been asked frequently
like hey
can't you
supply us with
data on how many
guests are in the swimming pools
like like in the swimming pool leaders
look
let's just because that's the cool
icelandic name i'm gonna go with that
and
so i've got so many requests from
various people
when are you going to bring us a
dashboard
on swimming pool like how many how many
guests are currently in new zealand post
like live data
and we thought like hey that's easy
um
so there are these gates that count in
guests
um in most of the swimming pools in the
week
but the thing is for some reason and so
one would assume like hey i just jumped
in and and then the gate comes out it's
just plus and minus this and everybody
is happy and and and we can maybe query
this gate and ask
like how many have you counted out and
counted in
so it turns out that
and these gates that are now in
operations most of them don't count out
and i have no idea why it's just
probably they were cheaper i don't know
but they are now in place they come in
so we know how many
guests have have gone into the swimming
pool but we don't know how many have
gone out of it so we have this
accumulation it's kind of kind of kind
of like like an accumulated distribution
that never comes back down
so how many people are in the simple a
million it's not true
to answer
so uh what do you do about that and
in one of these swimming pools leubzler
and
they also count out because they have
more advanced gates
so we have data on
how many
guests have been counted in and how many
have been counted out
so we have like a historical
distribution
um on
um
on
how long
each
guest is staying at the swimming pool in
the swimming pool like all right
and
so we can model that we can build up a
model that says hey so it's actually a
temp it's a time series model that can
predict like hey now now i have this
guest arrived at this point in time
according to my model which is a
linear spline model and you can go into
the details
if you want to but it's a linear spline
model that can predict hey it's this
time of the year and and it's at this
time
and i predict that guests
that are coming now should stay on
average 90 minutes so then we count them
out after 90 minutes and
and so
we count in and then we have a model
that counts out
so we have an accumulated distribution
with pluses and accumulated distribution
with minuses
and and then we can calculate a
uh some kind of estimate on how many are
in the simple during its
uh during every hour but the thing is
here we need to think about here comes
now
we think about this project as a data
scientist or we need to
we need to
zoom out a bit we and ask okay where's
the value
and
the value is knowing
approximately
at which capacity the swimming pool is
at i only need to know whether it's like
70 80 capacity or 20
i don't need to know as a guest whether
50 50 guests or 52 guests does that make
sense like you might be discouraged to
go to a swimming pool if you see it's at
full capacity
or you might not it like depends on your
needs
and
so
so then we are okay with errors but we
still need to have some way to
to
predict within certain degree of of of
[Music]
some estimations and with some degree of
uncertainty
so that's how we do it um we applied
that model to the other swimming pools
and we are currently asking those
uh swimming pool executives to
to
evaluate that this makes any sense but
there's a cats and this is why it is one
of our favorite projects
in the inlet that
it doesn't count out
that comes out
during some time during the day
the staff just said says to help with it
there are too many guests here we're
just gonna open the gates and and
reevaluate in the morning how many
guests were so so so we need to do some
estimation you know how correct the data
is
and i'm not going to go into those
details that they're very
minot and weird but uh but i really like
that and so
so yeah um
we have like this model running on in
our studio environment
it's like it's like the data comes in it
comes on to our studio and
a
computer that's in the azure cloud
there's the virtual machine
and then it clears the model like hey
how how many
like
for how long should this guest stay oh
he's going to stay for 90 minutes
and
and then it will do the the aggregation
of the processes minuses and then give
the feedback
back to the api and i just think it's
really cool
it's data science and some some some
arithmetic
yeah yeah not all of the projects are
like that but uh but we'd rather do that
than spend 10 millions per signing
chronos on new gates
would you say that's your favorite
project
top ten at least top five because it's
just it was so laughable it was so funny
to see that hey this is extremely
complicated
but uh but uh can we actually solve that
and it turned out that we could and
so that was fun
um
yeah so
we have other super interesting projects
and and and i think that this swimming
pool project is going to have a real
value for the
for the citizens of reykjavik because we
really love going to swimming pools and
this is just something in our dna
it's interesting like to think of like
our own
problems that we're solving where maybe
we have something it's the same case
where like at a certain point people
just open all the gates and so
now all the data is messed up like i
wonder what those are in individuals
yeah
absolutely
so frank casey you had a question
specific to
um
to the swimming pool example do you want
to ask that live
love to as soon as i'm off so uh
actually two things that come to mind
ollie like really interesting example
i'm trying to visualize how your team
worked on that over time and i'm curious
how many analysts scientists you had
working on it
just roughly like i know sometimes
that's tough to quantify right this
person a little bit sometimes yeah in
other words
and so i have a fairly accurate estimate
estimation of that um
so we we
so this has been i think
not counting this spammer location i
think it's been a four months project up
to this date
um the first hurdle was basically
getting um access to the data and that
took some time
and
since so
so being on like an official battery or
entity like riko city you need to make
sure when you're doing
contracts or
when you're acquiring things that
like inside in the case of these gates
like you need to make sure that hey the
data that these
date gates have generated they belong to
us and we will not pay an ounce or
krona for for getting these
data and that
and though that particular contract was
not phrased well enough so that took
some
took some discussions back and forth but
once that was out and they were taken
care of and
i think when we realized that
the gates were responding this way
um i think it's been
a month where we tried to
[Music]
figure out
whether we could actually solve this and
but that was not
the data scientist who was doing working
on this once was not doing that full
time
uh it was doing like maybe 25 on and off
but i think that is a good approach when
you hit a problem that is new and all
and unsolved not like business as usual
to just let it sit with you
and let let your unconscious mind work
on it
so
so let's say 25 for a month and now it's
up to now it's
ready and in testing
and
and but in actual time it's been four
months
and one data scientist and me as well
because because i can choose projects
you get to work on the best stuff yeah
yeah
yeah but it was just so interesting
cool yeah so
one other one of the things and um this
should be a quickie but i'm curious
after you built the thing and built the
model and built out the dashboard how
did you know how did you validate that
it was working did you like go to the
field and say like oh yeah great results
say 60
looks about 60 percent full yes so
almost like that so we asked the
um
you know
the swimming pools are being operated um
as a
like
like individual companies so they have
executives
so we asked them to to
compare like does this make sense
with what what you see and what you
think is true in your swimming pool and
that is like i think that is a good
enough evaluation yeah and without like
actually going and asking like you know
you're going to go out of the swimming
pool
according to my model you need to go
after 20 minutes
like
um but if it's in
with
i would say if it's within if you think
about proportions thinking about
like uh
capacity proportions like if you're
within like 20 accuracy i think you're
doing fine in this particular case
like
because it will not affect you as a
resident or a visitor whether 70 people
or 80 people in the swimming pool but it
might affect you if they're 10
or
10 000. um yeah depending on your needs
i'll volunteer to go double check
yes yes
i'll go hang out at the swimming pools
yes um rob i see you asked a question in
the chat too do you want to ask that
live
yeah well you kind of answered it a
little bit with uh frank's answer but
you talked about collaboration with
stakeholders and you know you're in a
sort of public service-esque position
and citizens are
your stakeholders i was just wondering
what what that actually
looks like
yes
this is a tricky one because i don't
think there's a single answer here
and
so i think we always need to bear in
mind that ultimately what we're doing at
the city are we are
we are servicing the residents and and
it's kind of just
even though you you are data scientist
and
then you just need to know this
your servant
you
serve them
but
i think the swimming pool example is an
interesting example because this is
something that uh many residents were
asking and we are getting frequent
requests it wasn't to me only but also
to the department that is responsible
for
operation of the operations of the
swimming pools
and through the departments like the
department of welfare school release or
other planning they get
there so
so what we're doing now so the york city
is going through digital transformation
phase
is that the departments have these
digital leaders and they need to be
aware of what is the most important
process for them
and that is ranked with respect to what
is important for their clients and
the
department of welfare has certain
clients who are planning
planning growth and stuff and they get
the needs from the residents through
their operation that that that
goes back to us but but i have a
particular project in mind
so we are we are starting now to build
up like this portfolio of uh data
products that is supposed to
um
be available on the web it's
supposed to be some kind of data market
or a data store or dashboard store for
for the residents of recovery
and
we i think that's a really cool product
and i think we should build that but we
can't do that without understanding the
needs of the residents do the residents
actually need to know how many bikes
were going around
here
every hour do they need to know that is
that something that helps them to go
through the day
so
and when we are building something that
is particularly for the residents of
reykjavik in
in a perfect world
that needs to be addressing some of the
needs that they have and and we have
done that with surveys and asking and
and having these open platforms for
residents to get ideas in
um so
some of these things have worked quite
well others haven't
but like for external data and and
external products that are like
especially made
for the citizens citizen you have to
like keep an ear open like listen like
in in the case of this calendar
uh data product that that is
trask calendar data product that that
was a screaming need somebody had to do
that
and and we listened
so
so this is in an active dialogue and
also by active listening so
i'd like to phrase it like that but
there's no one platform to decide that
if that helps
but uh
the city is a large institution spot
battery and
and
you you need to realize that
the employees in on all in other
departments they know
what their clients needs
and and and and they can give you that
feedback so you can build up these
products and they go so so i i have a
dashboard here so that i can serve you
guys if you want to
want to see it and which is particularly
aimed for the department of welfare
and and we built the dashboard with
their needs in mind so it was for the
uh so the department of welfare
is has in operations a lot of
institutions have had houses for their
clients and and they have employees
there and they need to know a lot of
things that i can't
i can't articulate of all of them but
they're important for their operations
and for and for people with special
needs so they know what they need and
they ask us to build that and we
have an open dialogue on how to
represent that and how to to get the
info from the from the data so that that
is a
another example of a data product that
is not necessarily an external one but
it's enhancing operation for a certain
subset of the population
so i like that and
i was just saying i'm sure you get a lot
of requests then if you're using all
these different formats for coming up
with ideas
i was curious how do you like prioritize
which projects the team works on yeah
this is a fantastic question and
with uh
with an interesting answer
so
the data team
belongs to a bigger department or is a
part of a bigger department that is
called department of service and
service and innovation
so
we are tasked with
the digital transformation
of the city of reykjavik basically
enhancing and building the digital
infrastructure
not only data and data science but but
the digital world as a whole
so
i would argue that if you're building
data products and and then supporting
data decision you're you're
you're a big part you play a big
supporting part
in
the digital transformation journey
so
with this digital transformation
changes and effort comes
comes a lot of investment so we are
responsible for
for
uh staggering amount of cash
in my mind in my simple mind it sounds
weird but it really isn't
um so
so the idea is our department is
responsible for prioritizing projects
and and and touching
and and so we built up this so we want
to do this in a data driven fashion
so we will build up this uh we call it
just the matrix and the matrix has
a certain factors in it columns or
whatever and and they are like
one of the questions that we ask that
belong to the majors like how is this
bringing value and to whom
and we have certain um
like rating range or or like a numerical
range that represents some
value like the highest score would be
brings a lot of value to employees and
residents
and we need to be able to articulate
that why it's bringing value and that
scores something and then we have other
factors that we scored by like how is it
supporting
the digital infrastructure or is it an
hindrance in some way or is it
alleviating some pain points or whatever
see we also have more
um
so we we have like these mandates and
vision like that we work by and
like does this current correspond to our
green initiative and also does this
correspond to equality gender equality
and and overall and embracing diversity
within a city we're trying to score
score i think if i remember correctly
it's seven categories and they're all
represented and
the numerical values have some um
meaning behind them so we
when we do this uh rigorously like that
um we get like a list of projects that
are scored efficiently
and then then we are in a better
position to argue
for doing things this way and since our
our like
we need to be responsible we need to
make the argument for our choices to
city council
and and
so when we do this and this
data-driven fashion is easier to
to define your position and if you can
think about it that way but but
it isn't built only for that it's built
for us to understand why we're
prioritizing projects
and
before we built up this procedure um
we chose project into the data team
basically just
like the first year was just being
cowboys and and and just taking
something that was interesting but now
we're more rigorous in thinking about
hey we need to build up a a data lake
hey we need to build up this and data
apis and
and all of that such that we can start
to
that we can
expand and grow
efficiently
um
so
there there's more a bigger part
like there's more to the story
and so the other departments they also
need to prioritize their project because
before they come into us
and we prioritize them and this is not
only data this is the digital
transformation effort as a whole
and
how we are the framework that we're
building is that we
we are injecting these change agents
into the other departments and we call
them digital leaders
and the teams ate and through digital
leaders and
they they um they work closely with the
department heads and they have a certain
mandate to
to work
and their task is to
to
get an insight into the operations of of
their departments and see opportunities
for digital transformation
so
they are touched with like
getting their hands dirty and trying to
find out hey here are pain points we can
do this this this and then they bring us
bring that to us so that goes to the
matrix and then we start cool
and then we go to work and
so it's extremely interesting and and
for the for the past half year for me
it is more like being a part of this
digital transformation journey than only
data science
data science plays a vital role
but it's just a piece of puzzle
yeah yeah little really long answer but
uh no
no that's helpful thank you
rick i i see you asked a few questions
in the chat that are related to the
story as well so i want to make sure to
pass the mic over to you as well rick if
you want to ask those live
you mean about about um getting what
they really need
well i see that you just asked um
about if like a department's needs
didn't match the required needs yeah one
thing one thing that i'm really curious
about is that um
especially i mean it's really nice that
you say you want to give them the value
and you really want to give them
something that is going to be helpful
but one thing i'm always kind of aware
of is that people don't know really what
they want because they don't know what's
possible and then it's really surprising
when you talk to someone that's not
involved in data science like you can do
that and they're really surprised and
it's something that's we think yeah like
like 20 years ago we can do that and so
um like when they don't even know what's
possible
how do they know really what they what
they want then do they how do you kind
of tease that out of them
that's the trick isn't it
is to is to
find this common ground
with somebody who's an expert in their
own business and their operations and
knows nothing about data science
and i think
the short answer is
there is no one single way to do this
but the long answer is have many
discussions and be aware of continuous
development processes
so
you can start out by doing something
simple and did you mean this
and have a player work on that
um then meet again i mean again i mean
again and
build something simple and build upon it
so i'm
i'm really fond of this concept of
continuous development and and
and building up some things like step by
step and i think what happens in a
process like that
if you have a good relation and open
dialogue with your stakeholder is they
realize that hey what
that's awesome right
and and just to give you a super simple
example like one of these
and dashboards that we are building that
is nothing to do with
machine learning or anything like that
like
we we use
packets in our called plotly to build up
graphs
and and you can you can slice and dice
on your dashboard and then filter out
the data and then you can
download the image
uh like that you can download the as is
like how it appears
and that was just a game changer for
somebody like and i had no idea that
they didn't realize that
you know there's a download like button
you could just press it
and and
this only happens because we we talked
frequently
and you just
yeah i i'm not sure about that there's a
silver bullet here but uh but i think
the approach is
dare i say humility and and realize that
nobody thinks the same
and
most people have no interest in data i
just
just
if you're okay with that like that
doesn't affect me as a person of my
interest
i'm just okay with explaining hey a
linear relationship that's something
that is
like looks like that and hey simpson's
paradox did you hear about that
like if you're just okay with that and
and
and also curious about their business
and
then something can happen i i think
the
um when you're meeting especially a new
client or a stubborn client or a
stakeholder that has a complicated set
of um procedures and a complicated
framework
then this this needs to happen gradually
and with humility like i i honestly
think that's the only way because you
can't come in hard you can't come in and
say like yes neural network no we're
going to do that
like
yeah so i have a story
do you think that people do that
they come in and they try to oversell
[Music]
points
you see the data scientists do that like
they come in and they try to oversell
and and push their idea
um
i can't just
i'm not sure i know i have done it over
the years and i have to learn this the
hard way
so i have a story to see when i was at
the bank um
and
and
so
we are trying to push the countries
there like we're trying to to
incorporate data science into many
aspects of the operations of the bank
and i i
remember quite distinctly this meeting i
had with
the department of the corporate
department and but we're trying to i was
i was building a model that can help
them
quantify and categorize companies that
that were not doing business with the
bank
so basically a clustering algorithm for
for companies and and clustering with
respect to their portfolio their
economical size and
and all of this all of these terms that
i don't know in english and something to
do with operations
but um
basically uh
what they did there
so the algorithm i used to to demystify
these numbers was i i normalized them
and and then i protected them on i am a
normalized space
and then i did some and clustering
algorithms and protected them back in
order to
understand that hey this company belongs
to this category that says
that says okay it's a big fishery or a
small bakery and and then why would like
to do that is because you approach these
companies differently with different
products
based on which category they build onto
and the and the approaches that i was um
adhering to was nothing new in
in in this world it's been done for for
decades
and i came in hard in a way that i i
started to
explain to them
how
the algorithm worked and how it is
superior to what to
the way they're working
so and that was coming from a good place
like i was i was trying my best to
explain i was made probably from coming
from a place of
of hey i need to
i need to
convince them that that this is correct
whereas what they needed was why does
this help me
not hey
they don't need to be convinced that the
algorithm is this way left
and so
so that what i mean is like
i just hit a wall there and i didn't
understand like
like
why are they not super excited about
this this is this is awesome
um
um
and the interesting thing there like
after that meeting and my my old
manager at the time just had this
discussion with me like
you came in way too hard and and and
and when you do that even you you were
always selling not necessarily
overselling but you're doing it
incorrectly or not
it didn't find this
this common ground that they needed
you were you were playing basketball
they wanted to play football or whatever
and and and so you just didn't
understand the game
and and i i like this was just so
distinct in my memory like
okay i need to be
the teacher i need to be
on their side and i need to like when we
went back to this and then we went about
this differently and talked about hey
this can help you sell products because
we know what kind of company this is
something like that and then like hey
yeah now we're playing basketball
whatever they're playing does this make
sense i know this isn't the general
approach but um
sounds like yeah sounds like your
ordinance story too data science is more
about people than about yeah
yeah
that's the insane thing like
yeah what i i'm super excited about ai i
teach ai at the university of iceland
but uh but employing it is so humane
like deploying it and operationalizing
it then and getting people on board
this happens through discussions because
i also had dialogues where my
the people i was talking to thought that
i was trying to take away their job
and i and what i was actually doing was
i was helping them and
and and because they
from their point of view
thought
this and i
then we couldn't have a discussion
until later when we just started again
um so
so especially for stakeholders that
don't see how it works
our students have been there for a long
time
um
you need to respect their boundaries and
respect their needs and that is not easy
that happens through
continuous dialogue and and trying to
inject ideas
being patient and
somebody are totally on board and that
is just awesome like i think they're
more and more like that
ollie kind of on a similar thread
there's anonymous question from slido
do you sometimes
meet with stakeholders or communicating
back and forth with them where they're
asking you for a specific product but
they don't realize or really accept that
you don't have the data to create that
yes yes i've been in this position
i've been in this position i'm going to
say several times so thinking about an
interesting
example um
i guess so in the case of a city like we
have so many full so much falsely data
and and click data that needs to be
cleaned so we we can't do the things
that they're asking of us uh right now
but then i try to say that but we will
do it that's what's bound to happen
but um i what i often think that and
so i'm gonna
i'm gonna go
a bit
back into my story like to the origins
and
the dark side of data science is
when your clients
want
a
certain result
but the data is not supporting it
that is something that is a darker
version of your question
uh
and i feel like
when you're in
if that if you're in that position in
your life or in your academic life
any professional life or academic life
and
never sacrifice your values and
for somebody else's needs
and that also
that also
is true for the more
more
benign
version of this um
if you don't have the data just
tell them and explain like i can't do
that i have an example though so
um
so
we need to
do a certain analysis for the department
of welfare and so this is data on
financial aid
but how the data is currently being
served into our data lake
and how we've how we accept the data
um
we accept it in an aggregated form
um
the reason
behind that is
um
the financial aid system was built this
way three years ago and also because
they're
at the time they didn't have
uh the gtpr regulations uh correctly in
place
to
get
more granular data so the data on
financial aid is aggregating on
predefined groups
but
when you have aggregated data you cannot
answer all of the questions that
you're being asked on certain groups
let's say it's aggregated on gender then
you of course can't answer aggregation
questions on on aids
or
or
is there difference in financial aids
between neighborhoods or or whatever and
you need to have this aggregate
this granularity to to to do the correct
aggregations
and i feel this is something that i'm
constantly in this discussion if i get
aggregated data then i can't answer
questions from grammar or data but going
into the granular data
then you're entering a more um
let's say more difficult discussion
because that that is something to do
with with gdpr regulations and
personal rights so
so yeah um
yeah i follow a question to this uh if i
can buy it because the the question of
making the data say something that it
doesn't which is it sounds like a very
clear ethical question but it reminds me
i think just last week there was a
really nice article i think it was an
economist i was trying to find it but i
can't find it and they had this report
where
i mean it's a phenomenon that we all
know that if you change the metric you
can change the results so there is a
relationship if you if you consider this
phenomena but there isn't if you
consider this it depends like how you
define it and it can be like oh i define
it measured by hour or i define it
measured by a minute yes like like
simpson's paradox right if you don't
agree so
if you
if they say to
say something opposite of what it says
that's unethical but if they say oh use
another metric that i'm going to be
happy with
then that's a bit of a gray zone and
then you'll do that and then it's also a
question of how they communicate and how
they use it afterwards which is out of
your control
absolutely and
this is something that
i think this is difficult when
when
you
you output a certain analysis certain
graphs and certain
inference on the data
and then it's out there then it goes to
the city council or
or the media and it's misinterpreted
and and and you know this that's
dangerous and i feel like
going into the 21st century i think one
of the most important upskilling um
upskilling skills or
something that people need to upskill is
definitely their data literacy
and and just now during the code
epidemic like
there's so much mis information up there
i was just reading a a interesting
article based on the data from israel on
vaccinations which is a
super example of the simpson paradox
and where where you could assume that
hey vaccinated people are are are
getting more affected than vaccinated
which is totally not true when you look
at the data in in a correct granular
form
and
just these things these are incredibly
important for enlightening discussions
and
sorry i mean um you hear this a lot that
people need to be more data literate but
i i would i would argue against it
actually the devil's advocate because
it's impossible to get millions or
billions of people to become that
illiterate right nobody says you need to
be auto literate you need to be iphone
literate you just get the iphone you do
it right nobody reads the iphone manual
so i feel it's like it's the designer's
job to make a product that's intuitive
and simple people use
and the iphone did that brilliantly and
it's the data scientist's job to produce
a data science product that is not going
to confuse so actually just this week i
had a similar thing where i produced uh
i produced a plot and i put a lowest
curve and it should not have been known
there but i like it so i did it and i
showed it to it was actually for a
friend in the company and i said okay
this is just fun but don't don't use it
it goes oh but i really like it and i
went to the shareholders meeting
yesterday and there was and i said i
told you not to use this plot this one
looks so nice and i was like so that's
my fault because i should i should just
not have given it because i knew it was
wrong
i should just not have you ever show it
to him right yeah i i agree with this
statement and and i certainly agree with
that um when you're when
when you
in a position where you need to see
important data and important analysis it
is your responsibility as a data
scientist or or a teacher or a knowledge
here to do it correctly and and and in a
way that it can be read
and not misinterpreted easily i i i
i agree with these this principle or and
and point of view that
uh there is a certain responsibility on
the shoulders of data scientists i
absolutely agree on that
uh whereas also i think that so that
like here in iceland we have like this
open course that everybody can take
which is on the basics of
of statistics or or ai yeah
it's it's super nice it's actually
supernova
but but absolutely um
with
can i just please quote comics like with
great power comes great responsibility
it's true it's just totally like that
i've been thinking about that a lot when
i mean especially with codewood but when
you scroll through twitter or linkedin
and you see all these like plots where i
can look at that and have no idea what
it's actually saying
um but how do you
how do you train people to do that or to
be able to communicate through
visualizations
yes um
that's a difficult question and
i guess like when i'm thinking about the
the products that we've made and they've
gone through so many iterations
and with my new changes and for color
schemes and and just color schemes and
scale
something like that that matters a lot
because
unconsciously you you like like blue is
cold red is hot like this is just
something that we think about
and all of these things um
need to have
their space
and need to have the discussion so what
we have been doing and and so we test
this with our
clients but we also have like just an
access access to awesome designers
that are thinking about this design of
digital products and we have meetings
with them when we're building our
products
and and and
just comments on on hey what are we
trying to convey here like these are not
the correct colors are just one of my
favorite most favorite discussions
so
so
i i would say in one sentence pay
attention to detail
and and
pay attention to us to aesthetics and
because great looking graphs
uh catch the eye
and and they have this like
they have their mental space
you know these old school access nobody
wants to look or
no person that wants to like print them
out and put them on the wall but you
want to build grass that you could
you have in your living room almost
but i i'm really like i'm really
um sold on this subject and i i'd like
to
um
just
there's so much out there like by hadley
wickham on on the subject
and interestingly he came to a
conference here in iceland in 2010 when
i was starting out my phd and i met him
there
and he told me like
if you spent
months doing research spent at least few
days to make sure that your graphs look
cool
and that's so true
like
make space for it yeah
i i know a few people have to drop as we
just get past the top of the hour here
so i want to be sure to ask you only if
people have other questions or want to
connect with you what's the best way to
do so yes so
you can find me on linkedin and i'd be
happy to talk there i think that is the
easiest way to contact uh to be in touch
with me
um yeah it's right there
thank you
i think that's like that's my more
unofficial like where i just hear
my professional thoughts not as the
chief data i'm sure
more like but what i think about data
science as a whole
and please reach out i think
this
forum that we have here is
incredibly valuable and it's so so cool
to see people from other countries and
all their origins
you'll be thinking about several things
as i am
definitely and i i know i talked with
your team a little bit about
maybe having a meet up in a couple of
months or so and
getting other cities together too and
create a working group yeah they're all
in and clean your expense of that and
and i'm totally on board
that's wonderful
if you have a few more minutes to stay
unholy there are a few other questions
yeah that's okay okay perfect i know
rory you had asked a question before i
wanted to make sure we got to around
like shiny app usage analytics if you're
still on do you want to add any uh
additional contacts there
yeah sure um i haven't really built many
shiny apps yet because a lot of what i
do is very heavily like research project
oriented
um i have mostly background in
organizational psychology and so i do
workplace behavioral analytics
um but i was curious with your your
swimming pool
dashboards and all that have you started
looking into
like the the user page or the use the
page use analytics to see okay is that
another kpi i can use or metric i can
use to say this is adding value to
people as opposed to just
the qualitative input you get from folks
yeah that's a fantastic question
and the short answer is no
but the long answer is
what we are paying attention so we need
to
this is where
something that we need to get more into
are which features on our pages on our
desktops being used the most
um
we haven't
but we have been paying attention to is
how many visitors or unique ip addresses
are coming
onto the web page as a whole but not
thinking about individual features
most of our products are just a single
page
and like for our
trash calendar so we also have a voting
dashboard and and we have all other
things
and
we can see that they're in frequent use
so that's how we
rationalize keeping them in operations
and but i'm thinking about for example
the
i think which is our coolest so we have
two really
big dashboards one is internal for the
city council called city watts
and that is our
huge
aim to
see
how the code epidemic is affecting the
citizens of regularly
in social economic means and and all
that
and i also have this welfare task what i
was mentioning earlier but what would be
super cool is to monitor which features
are being used most
so we can emphasize that beard
yeah but uh
next step
yes yeah
i guess a quick follow-up question if
you don't mind because i haven't done so
much of this i also wonder if i would
lose motivation at some point because
generally i feel like data scientists
are less
we might be a little less interested in
all the aspects of the web page
development
as opposed to the metrics that someone
could go and find out of them so i don't
know if you've thought about that and
thought hey do i need a data scientist
for this
is any are there any of them going to be
interested or is that where you pull in
a web developer who's going to be a
little more nuanced than that
that's a good question and
that's um
so in my mind when i i'm referring back
to the this
metaphor with the data pyramid that i
was mentioning earlier
what i call data ops that is sitting on
top of
data science
that can be
web development
and and i think that
if if you're
you're building data processes that are
supposed to sit on the web
or in
that aren't pure models or pure analyses
or insights that are more like
cool graphs that are in operations or
dashboards that are being used to slice
and dice
um i would argue a perfect team consists
of a specialized data ops
talent
that is that finds enjoyment from work
doing
web development
and
so there are two in my team that is as
one data engineer slash dead ops and
other data scientists slash datas
and in my discussions with them they
get
this job fulfillment from from doing
both
um so if in your particular case um if
you're mainly interested in data science
there is a place for that like like in
in reykjavik's team
um
there is one one that does only data
science and
but i think you need to be aware of
consisting like it depends on the size
of the company and and
and and and whether it's a startup or
not like you might have to be aware of
that you need to do some data ops
and and then it's nice to be able to use
tools that you're familiar with like cnn
so the
so you're still in r and so you could
still like and
speak your favorite language
so to speak
yeah yeah yeah
but this is this is a good topic and and
i think there's a certain merger between
uh
being a data engineer and being a data
scientist in data offs and i think
um
one needs to be okay with
doing a little bit of all of those
things
and yeah
yeah but uh hopefully
in the team
you
you can specialize in
a certain domain
like like for example if i had
a
data science problem that is
involved or convoluted
i would think that we'd like us
like build some cool models on top
i wouldn't ask the data arch people to
do that
right right
cool thank you thank you for answering
my question appreciate it yes yeah my
question
oh yeah i think there's one last
question that was was in the chat that i
wanted
to ask even though kevin i think had to
drop but he asked
about what was the data culture like
before you were working for the city
and i think i'd also like to add to that
question like what advice do you have
for other people maybe on the call or
listening in
to
maybe start to create this kind of data
culture
that you have now
so
when i came in
and those two years ago i think that i
was quite fortunate in the sense that we
already had this backup from
the city council and from the maturity
so i
it wasn't
one of the fights that i didn't need to
go into was convincing the city council
that data matters
they they are of the opinion
are still of the opinion that data
matters
and
but how it matters
was not clear to them and that was my
role to explain and and
exhibit
but changing the data culture and if you
so so more about the data culture when i
came in i think everybody was so at
least in my on in my department
people were relatively excited about
data and and thought about like oh data
science is something like something from
minority report
everybody has to see minority reports
like
it isn't like that but you can think
about things being like that
and but the truth of the matter was the
data culture was broken in some sense
and
meaning that
meaning that a certain
architecture was already in place i like
these are big words i'm not i'm gonna
i'm gonna rephrase it wasn't necessarily
broken the culture was in its infancy
and was ready to evolve but the
technology that was in place was was not
ready to scale up
and i would argue broken
so
the the technology that was already in
place and took a year to to unwind
was all
data that was supposed to be
used to do analysis to infer to connect
to everything
everything was carried out on a single
bi platform
everything all the analysis
all the detail
all the apis all the dashboards it was
insane
and and
some of the etl loads that were
implemented in the in this
uh in this bi platform were written in
language that nobody understands
and
and the culture was off in the sense
that
hey
we
we will pay
contractors to do our data science
and i would argue
you need to do data science within your
company because then you learn about the
data it isn't about the technology as
i've been
thinking been
discussing it's about
the business as a whole
the other stakeholders within the
companies and what the data is telling
you it has nothing to do with technology
and and
you know
outsourcing that the the inherent
discussions
the the the knowledge that the data
brings
to contractors
all of that you can you can outsource
technology but outsourcing the inference
and the learning on
learning from the data
that is bound to fail which it did
because then
the contractors can just say like they
have all the cars all of them
and and that was hap that's what
happened
um
i know
this is
i'm not generalizing this for older all
companies in the world but this just
didn't make sense for
reykjavik city
the operations
are
different between the departments and
the know-how is there
and yet you need to
empower
employees within the company
that know about their business
what the data is telling you not just
solving it other and
and
if i were to do this all again i would
do it again uh like this
changing the mindsets was have having
this discussion
is that like trying to point out in a
friendly and non-con confrontational
manner that
bringing
this work
into the fold
brings knowledge and know-how and value
and and i just did that again again and
again and again
um and the tricks there
i think is
if if there is a certain process a low
hanging fruit goal there then that can
be your your price that you're always
pointing towards hey we did that did you
know we did that we can do that with
data and having an example a success
story
helps and helps your journey and yeah
that's that's the wrong pleasure
thank you so much
thank you well i know we're a little bit
over so thank you so much for
all of your time and and the insights as
well i do want to just ask for anybody
that's still here were there any
questions that i possibly missed in the
chat that you want to ask live
one more quick thing i will ask you um
someone asked me to keep making this a
recurring question are there certain
podcasts or resources that you recommend
or things you
you listen to or read
yes
so
lately i've been more focusing on the
human side of things
and
so
for a team leader i would argue that
this
holds true
for everybody
not only the team leader or the
executives or monsters but there is a
book called five dysfunctions of a team
and that i would argue that everybody
needs to read that is who is working
within the team
and that has to do with realizing that
you can't do confrontation with you
can't go into just difficult discussions
uh on on subject matters
unless you have trust
so if you're working with somebody that
doesn't trust you on a certain
institutional level
you cannot have a discussion like that
and these
these discussions where we are
uh have different opinions where
opinions class
those are extremely valuable
everybody's voices needs to be heard
that that coincides always along the
lines of having a diversified team
but
that doesn't bring value unless
there's trust within the team
such that i'm okay with sharing my
thoughts and i'm not gonna get
um harassed or do it if i have different
opinions than the team
so so
type this if i were to suggest one thing
then it's five dispensaries of a team um
i'm
with respect to podcasts i'm really
mainly doing icelandic podcasts so i'm
not going to recommend them to you guys
they're more about
like having
i i don't know for the past year just
really
been thinking about
how to be a good person and and how how
to
how to
um
i'm trying to remember the name like you
can i can maybe just post it later on
but uh there are these certain rules
that if you adhere to that makes sense
like
confrontations they are never personal
always bring your always like be
consistent then always try your best but
i think like when you're having
difficult discussions that work on data
and like why are we not using my model
just remember it's never personal it's
never about you it's always about you
always about them
but uh um
and so there is a podcast on data
science that are it's called standard
deviation something i don't remember the
name i'm horrible with names
um
yeah yeah that is pretty cool
um and
that's being a good person one was
reminding me of the four agreements
yes that's the one it is the four
agreements yeah yeah read four
agreements it's short but uh
but it's just so comforting to to think
about when you're having confrontations
and you will have confrontations at work
when you're trying to move against the
type it's like hey it's never about me
it this is nothing to do with me and
then it just feels easier
sums up nicely your quote from the
beginning that data science is more
about people than about data and i feel
like if we were going to name this uh
recording something it would probably be
that
yeah yeah
human augmented ai or what or something
but uh so um what i'm listening to these
days i listen to a lot of sci-fi and i'm
listening listening to stories by craig
allenson called expeditionary force so
highly recommend it
well thank you so much jolie i really
appreciate your time and i'm so excited
to hear more about the team's story and
and do a meet up with them as well
yeah yeah and and thank you for having
me it's been a vivid and lively
discussion and
and all the best to you guys
thank you have a great rest of the day
everyone
you